hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
welcome back to my channel
this week i'm going to be answering your
property investment
questions so do me a massive favor
comment below in the comment box
any questions you have around property
investment and i will do my very best to
answer
your property investment questions also
if you enjoy my channel there's no one
in the uk
that has done as many property deals as
i have done who puts out as much content
as i do about property so if you
appreciate
my be taking the time to do this do me a
massive favor
smash the like button also don't forget
to subscribe and turn
on the notification bell do that right
now you want to succeed in this business
subscribe and do it right now okay so
what we got so
eek says the thing i don't understand
with packaging deals
is that once you sell the deal how do
you guarantee
good tenants like you promised the
landlord in the first
place um you can't
promise the landlord good tenant so to
answer your question
in short the answer is you just you
don't promise that you can you can't
promise anything like that you can't
promise that the market's going to go up
you can't promise that the refurb is
going to come up
exactly this amount on budget you can't
promise the tenants are going to be good
all you can do
is you can package it up you can present
the opportunity
and and you can do your research and you
just tell the investor what your
research is so for example you could say
there's a letting agent called honeybee
estate agents that have agreed to manage
the property
and have said that this area is a good
area and you're likely to get 650 pounds
a month rent
that you can say because that's factual
but what you can't say is you can't say
i guarantee that you're going to have
good tenants in this house
you just can't say that every investment
comes with some risk
and that's why you're going to have
terms and conditions that will protect
you which will
spell out exactly what you're selling so
really important
okay mabuba ahmed love the videos i'm
looking to buy a property
in a company but my accountant told me i
need an spv
and a holding company is this true how
would you do yours
so you do not need an spv or a holding
company
to buy a property in a company all you
simply need is
a company that's it however
if you are growing a portfolio it might
be that you do want a holdings company
especially if you're doing multiple
joint ventures you might set up an spv
a special purpose vehicle for every time
you do
a development project for example so you
know it might be worth
taking your accountant's advice or maybe
speaking to some other accountants
i don't know your situation i'm not
qualified to give tax advice anyway
but you definitely do not need a com um
all those things just to buy a house you
don't whether you should get them
if you're growing a portfolio is a
different story um but
and how do i do mine it varies from
property to property sometimes i'll buy
i'll be buying properties
and i'll do them as a joint venture i'm
not even on the title dudes
you know other times i'll put them in a
company i've got a lot of properties in
my personal name it just varies
property by property so yeah get second
advice from a second account and see
what you think
toby cox i have a question that may be
simple but i'm confused
i know that if you had a deal source in
business then you'd have to be compliant
but if you've got the odd property you
view as an investor
that doesn't work for you but you can
send it on to others do you have to be
compliant or not thanks for the help and
inspiration
so toby it's a really good question and
i don't think that
there is a black and white rule on this
like when i started packaging and
selling deals
people used to come to me and they'd be
almost paying me for consultation
you know be a bit like if you were a
mechanic and you know if your uncle's a
mechanic and you say
i'm gonna buy a car can you come down
with me and just help me choose
you know i mean that's one thing right
if you're running a deal sourcing
business
of course you need to make sure that
you're covered you've got the right
insurance
if you're doing the odd property
technically
the answer would probably be that you do
need to be compliant because if you're
selling a property to somebody
and you're charging a fee i mean you
definitely need contracts in place
you know if that doesn't work out what's
the protocol
so you probably should be registered
with the ombudsman so technically you
probably should be
if you are trying to sell a deal as a
one-off
and you're not compliant and you're not
registered and you haven't got a company
what i would say is just get
professional advice and always be
upfront
with the investor and tell them what
your situation is so
i hope that's helpful jamie mcdonald
when doing rent to rent if the landlord
owns the property before
article 4 and let it out as a single
letter could i then rent the house out
as a hmo
unfortunately you could not because
if it hasn't got planning okay article 4
means that when article 4 comes in
you need to get planning permission to
rent a property out as a hmo
it's not about the landlord it's not
about it's about the house
if the house is in an article 4 area and
it didn't previously
have hmo tenants you cannot change the
use of that house
so you wouldn't be able to do it as a
rent to rent hmo unfortunately enough
harry a how would you be able to get a
loan aged
17 and how do you refinance a house
i bought my first house at 17 i bought
it and then refinanced it
however at 17 you're not even old enough
to buy a house
so if you're so if you're that young you
might have to do what i did
which is find a family member who's
happy to put it in their name
with a view to them switching it back
over to you later years
okay cleo jones samuel i want you to
visit one or two previous winners on the
wednesday contestants and share an
update with us sure i can do that i do
do that actually from time to time
i'll bring someone back a year or two
later and i'll say what's going on now
and
i'll get an update um windows on a
wednesday is crazy because
i have so many people applying to be on
winners on a wednesday
and there's just so many good success
students it's incredible
like i could probably do winners on a
wednesday every day
but yeah i'll definitely take your
advice dream chasing 247 i've been
working
on this deal for about three months okay
the mortgage is in principle
and the survey was booked on the
property however the seller has now
changed his mind and doesn't want to
sell the property anymore oh
so sorry i feel you're paying i've paid
the broker's fees list of fees and money
for searches and survey
ah what to do next what's the fastest
way
um all right so first thing is i feel
your pain that's a real it's a real
shame when it happens
it might be that the money that you've
paid
to your mortgage broker and solicitors
maybe even
can be carried over onto the second
property it just depends on how much the
work they've done
for that particular property you're
definitely not going to be able to carry
out all the
switch over all the fees for example if
a mortgage broker says to you oh
you know you need to pay me a 400 pound
fee up front to just
start the ball rolling and you just paid
it and now you go oh man the property's
falling out there's a good chance that
they might
carry that money or at least some of
that money forward
same thing with solicitors it can happen
so maybe speak to them and see if you
can do that
and everything i want to say is although
it's really annoying what happened
and that's why sometimes it's nice to
buy from
auction or to put a lockout agreement in
place um
although a lockout agreement won't even
potentially stop that if he doesn't want
to sell at all
it is annoying the flip side to that
being annoying
is you can also pull out as well when
we're buying properties in england
and in most countries not scotland but
if you agree to buy a property you agree
it
in principle but it is always subject to
and you can
pull out and walk away at the last
minute so although that's annoying
and in scotland they just say you can't
do it at auction
you can't do it generally when you're
buying a property through an agent you
can do it
it also it does give peace of mind
because it means you can put forward an
offer
without having to spend loads of money
on surveys and stuff
before you put forward the officer it's
just an unfortunate thing
and i hope that you can carry forward
the fees
josh warburton how would you recommend
to pick a strategy also would you
recommend on picking your property patch
or how would you recommend picking your
property patch um strategy
depends on what you want to achieve
property is a vehicle that will get you
to where you want to get to
so if you're right now thinking should i
do hmos
should i do refurb should i do i'd say
i'd flip it back and say well actually
what do you want to achieve through
property
what's the purpose do you want to get
out of your job
do you want to invest and build up
capital appreciation
what is it that you want to achieve and
then when you know what you want to
achieve then you can go right now what
strategy is going to help me get there
also i wouldn't just have one strategy
i'd have multiple strategies up your
sleeve
and then just go and view properties and
become a property problem solver
in terms of area what areas should you
pick pick an area that you know well
which is going to give you a good return
on investment
you know where you buy low rent high an
area where you can buy low
where you're going to get good roi and
you know the area
and if you don't know any areas like
that go and find an area
and figure out the market phil on sorry
fight on oh
anyway this question if i were into the
property game i can't think of anyone
i'd rather have on my side than samuel
he's just not the type to do
failure great i appreciate that it's not
really a question or a statement but
in terms of failure i'm not against
failure as long as i'm
failing forward okay i think it was john
maxwell that said that
or i'm failing my way to success you're
gonna fail
in this business you know you're gonna
get rejected you're gonna fail so i'm
okay with failure
what i'm not okay with is quitting the
only time to quit something is to do
something else greater
so if i say i'm gonna quit this to do
this that's okay but just say oh that
was just a dream
no it's too hard and then quit i'll
never do that so
yeah quick being failure is not really
something that
uh i i'm not okay with just coining
something because the going gets hard
you are right on that all right aaron
morgan
when property sourcing what's stopping
the investor from backing out of the
deal before the 14 day calling period
getting the refund and then going to the
vendor behind your back
um aaron morgan what's stopping them is
a contract
a contract people sometimes forget that
when you've signed a contract
or even got an agreement over email
you can't just then go actually i don't
want to do that
lest you get sued and and
and everything is this don't don't ever
just think
oh you know what though i wouldn't sue
them anyway so there is too much hassle
so they might just not sue them
if if someone's got a contract and they
break the contract
you can take them to small claims court
and you will
win you will win so it's not
wishy-washy maybe maybe
that's why you need a contract don't
ever
take money from somebody without having
a contract in place
even if they're your best friend even if
they're your brother
you need clarity you need a contract and
in the contract it will say
that they can't try and buy the property
or cut you out
without paying your fee it will say that
they can't try and pass the property on
somebody else it will say
that will all be in the contract so yeah
and you don't need to pay thousands and
thousands of pounds to solicitors to
have a contract either people will say
unless your solicitor draws up the
contract it's not legally binding
bs it's not true
it's not true a contract if you go if
you're in the small claims court and you
go look this is what he signed the judge
will read it and we'll make a decision
he won't go well hold on there was this
especially drawn up by us was
no it's there black and white people
don't know they're naive because they've
never
i've sold hundreds of deals i've been
i've been in this game for 12 years i've
had a lot go good and i've had some go
wrong
you know so you don't need to worry when
you understand the law and when you
understand compliance in property like i
do and you need
you can too it's not that hard jamie
wants when viewing a property for sale
why is it on some occasions the house is
completely empty
i.e no carpets wallpaper skirting ripped
etc especially if you know it's not a
flood or fire damaged
i don't know i don't care i mean
probably maybe it's because
the house was so bad the carpets were so
stinky and old they just thought let's
just rip it
maybe it's because they started a refurb
and then they started it and then
thought man this we've
we've took the wallpaper off and we've
been off a little bit more than we can
chew here let's just sell the house
because we've not got the money to
finish it i don't know
i don't care you know i'm not really
bothered i just think about it's a lot
of people try and figure out stuff you
know i go around property viewings and i
go
what did this used to be i wonder what
this what are they selling what's the
i'm like i don't care man
just give me the deal and is it a good
deal i'll put it through my calculator
and if it's good i'll
buy it if it's not i won't i'm gonna try
and figure out why this why that
i'm not gonna sign up to that class um
but anyway great question
well yeah subscribe you're gonna
unsubscribe now
anyway next question max seaman
how do you handle utility bills within a
hmo
within a hml i pay the bills and the
reason i pay the bills is
convenient sales and when in 2021
nothing sells better than speed and
convenience
and when you're trying to rent a room
out and you're able to just say
all the bills are included it's
furnished they just come in and then
they go out and it's just simple
for them and for me you're going to pay
the bills
but then you're going to charge
considerable amount extra per room
because of that convenience and how
you're gonna pay the bills on the hmo
um i use utility warehouse because i've
got some friends who are distributors
i'm just gonna have a monthly
direct debit paying the bills in my name
and then the tenants are all gonna come
in you don't want them setting up
each tenant trying to set up it in their
name and then six months they move out
and you've got all the admin problems
you know
just pay the bills in hmos russell
petry rent to rents have you tried dover
i actually haven't tried dover i imagine
dove would be a pretty good area
that's where the ferry the ferry goes to
france right
so i've been on that ferry i imagine it
would work
i've never done it let me know how you
get on last question
trillionaire hi samuel i'm looking to
get a lease option agreement as my first
property investment
do you think it'll be worth getting a
simple two bed terrorists as a lease
option agreement
for say 300 pounds a month cash flow or
do you think i should look even further
for a better deal first
drilling an air if you've got a lease
option agreement
and it's making you 300 pounds a month
profit
and you've got good expected capital
appreciation i would absolutely
do it for your first deal here's the
rule of thumb at least a rent to rent i
want a minimum of 500 pounds a month
cash flow
why because you don't own it and you're
not benefiting from any capital
appreciation so if you're renting rent
you're just controlling it
if you're not making 500 pounds a month
it's not worth it lease option agreement
you actually benefit from any future
capital appreciation
so if it's making you three with a lease
option i say minimum of 200.
any less than 200 and you might end up
if you have a bad month
losing money you don't want to lose
money but if it makes a couple hundred
pound a month
and it appreciates worth it 300 pound
get that deal
sign that deal obviously i've not seen
it do do your normal due diligence on it
but yeah throwing to panama is really
good hey folks i love doing this i love
answering your questions
in order for me to answer your questions
guess what i need
questions so please do me a massive
favor and comment your questions in the
comment box below
also smash the like button and subscribe
to the channel and i look forward to
seeing you on the next video thanks so
much peace out
[Music]
you